china hits alibaba with a
record-breaking 2.8 billion dollar fine
for behaving like a monopoly this is a
cnn business story
china has ordered alibaba to pay that
2.8 billion dollars after antitrust
regulators concluded
that the online shopping giant had been
behaving like a monopoly china's
chinese state media reported saturday
that the state administration for market
regulation has imposed a
penalty following an antitrust
investigation to alibaba's exclusive
dealing agreements that prevented
merchants from selling products on rival
e-commerce platforms
a practice known as choosing one from
two the fine is equivalent to four
percent
of alibaba sale in china sales in china
2019 state news agency reported
in an open letter published on saturday
alibaba said that the company has
cooperated with investigation and
accepted a penalty
with sincerity and will ensure our
compliance with
determination right now let me give you
some timeline security
10 24 you know what happened on october
24th
ma gave that speech criticizing
regulators
november 3rd ma ant ipo was halted
in hong kong do you remember we talked
about it in the podcast jack went
missing
jack went missing right around two days
after 10 24
jack went missing okay on 11 10 november
10th
beijing drafts an anti-monopoly rules
for internet that's november
10th they write it that's three weeks
after his speech
december 24th beijing launches
anti-trust
probe into maz alibaba
uh uh uh organization and they
summon ant executives that's on december
24th day before christmas christmas eve
december 27th beijing demands ant
overhaul
this is december 27th okay now this is
two months after ma's speech
february 7th beijing releases a new
anti-monopoly rule for internet this is
new remember the first one they did that
on november 10th
well three months later they did a new
one that they released on anti-monopoly
on 4 10 april 10 two days ago they fined
them 2.8 billion dollars you know what
they're saying
uh hey entrepreneurs don't mess with us
you're not bigger than us we can do
whatever we want to do
to you u.s can do the same thing if they
want to to crypto
to write new rules and regulations janet
yellen is salivating
your girl she's salivating to get her
hands on
crypto today they're salivating now is
that why she keeps dogging it of course
yeah and you'll hear a lot of them
saying things like the following
you'll see crypto communities say if you
really understand bitcoin
you would know they can never regulate
it okay which i get the argument there
but if you really understand the track
record of the us government and
government period
they have always figured out a way in
federal to regulate
whatever the hell they want to regulate
because you crypto community or
competition
to them correct the best news here
is the big dogs are also entering
the crypto space jp morgan chase goldman
sachs morgan stanley all these guys so
that's what i mean when you say what is
your biggest concern that's what i mean
by what china's doing us could
potentially do as well yeah
but that's not all bad to have some sort
of regulation around crypto
to have some to prevent fraud first and
foremost it
it it depends on who you're saying that
to yeah you have an audience that's
going to say we agree with you you have
an audience that's going to say what the
hell are you talking about adam here you
go again
with more regulation and buying into
what janet yellen wants to do with the
new regulations
okay just giving you both sides also
come out and said that they're going to
potentially work on a
digital dollar from the u.s government
not to compete
with the dollar but to complement the
u.s they have already you know when they
say they're printing money how do you
think they print the money it's
digitally they don't print the dollars
like go print it
the dollar is printed digitally not a
hundred percent of the money that they
print
it's in printing press you just blew my
mind i didn't know that i thought they
literally printed the money no they
print digitally even
they themselves have digital
right i mean i mean hard cash currency
is only a small part of the economy
exactly
exactly digital printing is what they're
doing going ma
is clearly in the cross hairs this is
only be his nightmare is only beginning
and you know frankly it's a communist
country i i think
he should be very grateful the fact that
he built what he did and was
able to couple other things that you
know g is the the president is the one
that literally
personally shut down the ipo he's the
one that made the decision
personally all by himself the other
thing that the chinese government is
doing here is they're trying to go after
alibaba's data right because they have
one billion customers
they have all this information on their
buying habits on their credit habits
and that's another thing that alibaba
and ant group has turned into is almost
like a bank
in china they're giving out low interest
loans and that's the other thing that's
interfering with what china's trying to
do so you know
not only has his profile gone down he
still has not been seen in public
jack ma has not made a public appearance
he did that tape thing in front of the
school
maybe in january that was the first
sighting of it all but he hasn't been
out in public either so
this is very interesting he's worth 47
billion dollars right now
alibaba is huge it's it's you know it's
chinese amazon it's incredible and it's
not going anywhere
ever now that people are used to buying
everything online but
this is something really really
interesting to follow and whatever
happens to him could he could never
leave
maybe he's out of the country do you
think he could just pack up and leave
and be gone
maybe maybe he's maybe he's done there
who knows oh
but what leaves with you the the problem
isn't leaving
you know you know the guy spoke to
medicalvan who bought people's uh
nft for 69 million dollars he said the
reason why i've never moved to
california moved to state
is because of the fingerprints and all
the way of controlling you he says i
don't even want to go into the u.s
system because once i'm there they're
not even letting me take my money with
me
so imagine if so many people in america
are worried that if they leave your
money's tied up you can't take it out
this is why they criticize offshore
america
that's america let alone free as china
so you think the guy can take his money
from china yeah he may be worth 50
billion in china he's probably worth
half a million
in a different country unless he stashed
some of it over the years and could see
this coming because
how could this party not end for him
there is no way you could think that you
could continue
to drive let me give you another
situation say he moves to singapore you
think they would still find a way to go
get him
you think he means physically talking
about the tcp
of course take him go to uk you think
they would say you better give him to us
he has to go to a country
that hates china and is not allies with
china that wouldn't sit there and say
we're not going to do anything you know
so it's it's uh
jack ma is not bigger than china no one
in china is bigger than china yeah so
well like you said there uh this is a
lesson for all entrepreneurs in china
you know look at this last quote that we
talked about on on this uh
on this segment an open letter published
on saturday alabama said the company has
cooperated with the investigation and
accepted the penalty
with sincerity and will ensure our
compliance and determination
right right you think they're happy
about this you think they're happy about
their 2.4
2.8 billion dollar fine no but they
learned their lesson and this is a
lesson for every other entrepreneur
every other country
other companies saying let's shut our
mouths i've got the perfect advice for
jack ma this is what he should have done
he should have moved to america and
married mackenzie bezos
he's a former school teacher she would
have loved him that's a good point
she would have been all over you know
what screenmatch.com how about
center.com
there it is center.com matches
billionaires together it's only got 400
members
it's only got 2200 members another
callback that we can talk about last
episode with ricky you talked about
the communist component of it the
government component of it but also the
capitalist component of it
it's a weird situation here where you're
free to be an entrepreneur and
and to an extent to an extent but then
the government steps in and
yeah so to an extent where you have to
you have to bow down and realize
you your voice cannot be more powerful
than the voice so
so there's one thing that's missing in
china it's called what freedom of speech
you don't have freedom of speech in
china
right let's just face it you just don't
have freedom of speech in china
okay what what what do people who win
want to do
what makes smart brilliant people all
they want to do say what they want to
say by the way think about it
go a little bit even deeper do you have
some opinions that you want to share
with the world
do you have some ideas about how you can
make china better
do you have some ideas what you can do
to make the government of china better
do you have some ideas
if you're any intellectual human being
where you got like you know what if we
did it this way like imagine me saying
hey we should have a fifteen percent uh
right uh tax on tourists right and the
next thing you know valuetainment
podcast disappears maybe the podcast
disappears
that's exactly what ma did that's the
point you can't do that
in china but don't you think jackman
knew that before he said something
couldn't it be that nice no i felt i bet
you think you didn't know
i think you get very comfortable in a
situation like that remember that dog
and pony show that he came out to the us
and was you know going to silicon valley
going to wall street being treated like
a god coming to hollywood
i believe you can believe some of that
in your mind and you think you're
untouchable
uh look the the thing over there with
jack ma the only thing i can speculate
again this is speculation the only thing
i can speculate is the foul
so uh the rock
right 220 something million followers on
instagram he keeps coming out with a new
product every other day
okay i love his products that we mix
with under armour when he comes out with
it i like it i support it
so he's retweeted some of my stuff hey
pbd thanks for you know
buying the products i like his gears i
quite frankly i never liked under
armour's shoe it sucked no it's horrible
until the rock showed up i didn't even
know we had one now i'm going to check
it out
we were just talking about how ugly
under the rocks shoes are
the flipping bombs i'm checking
i like their outfits i i hated their
shoes by the way shout out to steph
curry just to be
scored fifteen chambers not 50 something
points but
last night he scored 53 points did he
score 53 points oh he had ten threes
that's right he
became the leading scorer yeah look at
this they're not like this right here
that's the one i bought
they're so comfortable when you slip
them on right
they kind of look european though so
he's killing it
just go to the red shoes of rock look at
these shoes he created
so he kills it with shoes then he goes
and kills it kills it with his uh
tequila tequila
have you tried it i have not i have is
it good if you're used to drinking
casamigos which i
am if i drink uh uh tequila it's
casamigos it tastes nothing like that
it doesn't have that kind of agave vodka
why don't we just are you here thursday
or you why don't we
are you here next time on the podcast
okay thursday why don't we order a
bottle
and on the podcast let's i've never have
you ever had it or not i have not so you
and i have never had it i've never had
it let's do a sample on the podcast and
see what it tastes like are you saying
that we're gonna do some day drinking is
that what you're saying no i mean
a little bit by the way i will say this
about the rocks
it's economical it's 32 bucks for a
decent sized bottle that would be 48
dollars for costume because
i agree he's killing it so then he comes
out with a zoa water let's get a bottle
of that as well
it's so funny we're not even doing a
sponsorship here this episode is brought
to you by the rock
but here's where i'm going with this
yeah the only thing i said i started off
by saying i'm speculating so my
speculation was what
my speculation is jack ma is sitting
there saying what's next for me i'm the
richest man in china the world knows me
i'm the most
influential man in china when you think
about china you don't even know
most people don't know china's president
or prime minister they know
jack ma more than they know him that
probably won't work
more than she that probably rubs him the
wrong way not ma that probably rubbed
zhi
the wrong way she says what if i make a
run at it so when you want to make a run
at politics what do you have to do you
have to start talking and giving some
political messages for people to kind of
say
i like this look what happened when the
uh the guy in china and russia did it
yeah putin comes out and says i can go
on re you know what do you call it
another
uh uh uh three terms three terms two
terms i'm also the sexiest man in russia
russia so china's saying that's not how
we choose
prime ministers and presidents here
that's not how we choose it we choose in
a completely different way so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you